good morning I'm Abby and welcome to Pi
data New York City
2023 we are gr to have you all here
gathered to explore the incredible
advancements in data science and learn
from one another over the next two days
we have exciting lineup of speakers
three Keynotes and 44 talks the QR code
will bring you to the pie data
conference website with the latest
updates on the schedule and speaker
information you'll get the opportunity
to ask our keynote speakers questions in
our Fireside Chats that are held at
Central Park
East little tour are by Microsoft space
on the sixth floor we have Central Park
East West and Radio City on the fifth
floor we have Winter Garden and music
box t-shirt tables will be on the fifth
floor so be sure to grab one and lunch
will will be available on both the fifth
and sixth floors so if the line's a
little bit longer on one floor
definitely check the next you can stop
byy the sponsor boots set up on both the
fifth and sixth
floor for Wi-Fi the network is called
Microsoft guest click on the blue atiny
button and here's the code it's also
written on the
whiteboards we have an amazing lineup of
extracurricular activities including HB
quiz which is during lunch today so grab
your food and head to Winter Garden on
the fifth floor it's hosted by James
Powell and you can come as a team or
find one when you you arrive it's a fun
way to learn something new or show off
your
knowledge we have professional head shot
which will also run during lunch day and
tomorrow on the sixth floor Lounge area
you can sign up on the spot and we'll
email you the photos after the
conference
following lunch today we have lightning
talks on in the Central Park West room
um they will be 5 minute talks and
signups are at the num Focus booth on
the fifth floor first time speakers are
encouraged to sign
up lastly for our extracurricular
activities we have Cod DS which is a
friendly python coded competition
happening at Central Park East after the
Fireside tracks and is available
throughout the day on Thursday and
Friday the winners will receive prizes
in the form of O'Reilly python
books also happening today after the
conference is our Atty social at hter
alley from 5: to 7:00 p.m. it's a 5 to
10 minute walk from here and um we'll be
at um the party area upstairs to claim
your free drink ticket bring your
conference
badge we expect all speakers and atton
needs to abide by the code of conduct to
read the code of conduct scan the QR
code you can also find it on our website
to make a report please reach out to
team members listed here um if you're
having trouble locating a code of
contact team member you can look for
volunteers wearing a white high data
t-shirt and if you need anything else in
general feel free to flag down a
volunteer for
help finally a big thank you to all our
sponsors be sure to visit the groups on
the fifth and sixth scores we also have
a job board on the website where
opportunities that our sponsors are
hiring for so um check that out on our
website and with that I'm excited to
introduce to you today uh the chief data
analytics officer of New York City who
will be giving us welcoming remarks we
learned that she's been to a pi data
events in the past so happy to have her
back please join me in giving a warm
welcome to Mar
[Applause]
noric thank you so much Abby I'm so
excited to be here let me just get set
up with all my
beverages all
right hello good morning my my brief
here was welcoming remarks which makes
me sort of what tempted to just yall
welcome in you and then like run out of
the room but I'm not going to do that um
I'm very excited to be here this morning
as Abby as you uh dive into day two here
of of Pi data NYC as Abby mentioned I
have attended this conference in the
past um and but before I get started how
many of you live in the five burrows
raise your hand o all right how many of
you have traveled here from far field
outside of the greatest city of the
world oh all right I'm sorry for all of
you but welcome welcome to New York I'm
happy to happy to welcome you on behalf
of of New York City government and the
uh office of data analytics um I
remember sitting in this in the audience
here uh I think it was was 2014 was uh
the last P that I attended um and and
just started feeling like this intense
impostor syndrome like oh my God like
everybody's so smart and I don't really
belong here um uh and 10 years later I
still feel that way so thank you so much
for having me and I'm thrilled to be
here in the presence of so many
brilliant uh python enthusiasts um so as
AB said my name is Martha noric I am the
chief analytics officer of the city of
New York um I'm a little biased but I
think I have one of the coolest uh data
analytics jobs out there um I lead the
office of data analytics which is now
housed within the office of technology
and Innovation like a little Russian
nesting doll of offices um and we were
established in
2012 to with a mandate to help the city
use data to improve government
operations since the very beginning our
office has used open- Source tools like
Python and R to to analyze New York
City's many sources of data in addition
to being analyst ourselves we also
support an incredible community of folks
uh across the city who work in data and
analytics in New York City's many
agencies and offices some of which are
here today shout out to Chey uh and help
them level up their skills in the areas
of replicable analysis Version Control
and open-source software New York City
runs on the data generated by its
agencies nearly every inter action New
Yorkers have with agencies produces data
from achieving a milestone like opening
a business uh or buying a house to
Everyday activities like having hailing
a taxi or having a very large permanent
picnic uh every public service that the
city provides for New Yorkers generates
data as well every tree that we plant
every restaurant that the city inspects
um every street that's paved is a row in
a data set we use this data to
understand understand how to better
serve New York City and in turn New
Yorkers and those of you visiting the
great town of New York City from out of
New York um are uh can use the same data
to understand how the government works
for them um one way you may have
interacted with our office is through
New York City's incredible open data
program uh R by a show of hands who has
used New York City open data before all
right excellent um I feel like it's like
a rate of passage for everyone that goes
to graduate school to uh to learn how to
use New York City open data so it's nice
to nice to meet you all um the New York
City open data program is run by a
dedicated team at the office of data
analytics it's fueled by the belief that
access to data promotes transparency and
grants new opportunities to the all who
use it that belief is backed by New York
City's open data law which was passed in
2012 if you love open data or just
curious about what folks are up to with
open data we encourage you to check out
nyc.gov opendata and also join us at New
York's annual open data week coming up
in March um it's incredible week of free
programming celebrating this wonderful
public resource um and right now we have
an open call for proposals if you want
to host a session at open data week we
would love to have you um you can find
the call for proposals at nyc.gov
opata so what types of questions can we
are using this incredible uh data
resource a lot of our work um takes the
form of scarce resource optimization
type questions um you know if we can
inspect you know a certain number of
buildings or properties in a given week
which buildings are the buildings that
are most likely to have tenants that are
that are being harassed by their
landlords um or which buildings are most
at risk for a fire um or which buildings
have uh conditions that we know are
associated with substantiated rat
complaints down the road uh we are using
python every day to answer uh these some
of the most interesting and impactful
questions around government service um
and well we never really know what the
day will hold um we are never
bored uh this bring me to the last thing
I wanted to tell you all and and sort of
have you think about while you're
kicking off your day here um which is
that all of you have these incredible
skills which you have worked extremely
hard to learn and you're here to even to
learn even more about how to use Python
and how to uh to work with data um these
skills you can use in the service of
many things um and my charge to you is
that you all find a way to put these
incredible skills to use um in the
service of your people whoever those
whoever those people might be maybe
there's New Yorkers maybe it's your your
community that you're came from maybe
it's your neighbors whatever um and
maybe that looks like exploring
opportunities in public service which I
would be so happy to talk talk to
anybody who's interested in making a
transition to working for the government
it's really cool I swear um we welcome
you with open Open Arms um but I know
that's not for everybody so maybe it
looks like volunteering with the many
organizations that help pair people with
your skills um with good projects public
good projects that could use them or
maybe it's taking on a Civic technology
project of your own just
independently um and you uh you know
building something that others could
benefit from I know you will all come up
with creative and wonderful ways um to
put your skills to use and hopefully
also put New York City's data to use um
thank you so much for inviting me to
welcome you this morning and share these
thoughts and I know you're going to have
an amazing day and I'm going to turn it
back over to
Abby thank you Martha for taking the
time today to give us an incredible
welcome and sharing your experience